[Applause]
Leena
Louis Prima cozy ozone aqua purty para
Brad charity Burbage RT / k Eredar tanto
tempo Kanata video style finish
so emotional to be here my god Wow but
we have to go on yes the first film we
made together Lina was a little over 40
years ago but the objective flow like it
was yesterday yeah passionate playful
honest and brilliant the truth is anyone
who has worked with Lina knows that she
is all those things and more when you
meet her you understand immediately that
you are in the presence of incredible
talent but even more than that she is
around forgettable woman and artist
who's made history by being yourself my
heart I wish I could speak each other
it's very difficult very difficult the
anxiety is there there is no question
about it you can see it okay but I will
go on because I am strong
the record over there no way the record
of her films is legendary and speaks for
itself the first woman to receive an
Academy Award nomination for directing
and for other films in the early
seventies yes the seduction of me me
love and anarchy swept away and the
seven beauties
we're just instant classics but like all
great works of art are cinematic
masterpieces that have stood the test of
time there are those who say this
recognition is long overdue but I prefer
to think it is long deserved and long
earned and the true honor for me to be
here to recognize one of cinema's
all-time great directors Nina Iroquois
[Applause]